[Musique]
je rends compte de nombreuses
difficultés à l'école ne serait-ce qu
écrire j'ai beaucoup de mal à écrire
pour faire un exercice ou rédiger une
leçon
[Musique]
j'ai une avait ce qui m'aide pour de
nombreuses choses au collège par exemple
me déplacer en deux ans et demi j'ai
changé deux fois d'avé s et lamont aves
malheureusement ne peut pas être là tout
le temps même si j'en ai besoin
par exemple à midi pour manger elle
n'est pas toujours là où pendant la
récréation quand j'ai besoin d'aller aux
toilettes
elle n'est pas là donc je suis coincé et
je peux pas me débrouiller quand elle
n'est pas là mon avs ne sait pas
toujours comment me relever quand par
exemple quand je tombe ou même quand je
suis assis dans mon fauteuil et que je
voudrais me relever elle ne sait pas
toujours comment faire ce qui est
pénalisant
[Musique]
je me rends à l'école avec un taxi
spécialisé spécialisés c'est un une
petite camionnette qui a une rampe dans
laquelle je peux rentrer avec le
fauteuil électrique
sauf qu'en début d'année il n'y avait
pas le transport
donc je mes parents devait m'emmener au
collège sauf que je pouvais pas prendre
le fauteuil électrique parce qu'ils
pèsent environ 120 kg il peut pas
rentrer dans la voiture
donc j'étais obligé de prendre le
fauteuil manuel donc j'avais une mois
grande autonomie
[Musique]
quand par exemple il ya une sortie
scolaire
loria le bus aménagé ça c'est très bien
il ya tout qui a ménagé et par exemple
une fois au musée un ascenseur qui
marchent pas et je ne peux pas suivre la
la je peux pas suivre le groupe donc des
fois il ya tout qui est très bien
organisée mais il suffit qu'une fois une
chose ne marche pas et il ya tout qui
tombe à l'eau
[Musique]
la maladie d'apollo est connu comme
étant incurable et pourtant tous les ans
on doit faire les mêmes démarches
administratives
on doit rencontrer des différentes
commissions on doit faire des
différentes demandes si les
administrations travailler de façon plus
étroite avec le corps médical peut être
que la prise de décision serait beaucoup
plus rapide
ceci permettrait aux familles de
bénéficier plus rapidement des
différentes aides et ça ça serait au
bénéfice de la qualité de la vie des
malades de la vie de famille de tout le
monde pour les enfants qui sont dans la
même situation que moi je voudrais leur
dire qu'il faut continuer à se battre
malgré toutes les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer au quotidien
il faut essayer de les surmonter même
s'il des fois on voit pas comment j
invite emmanuel macron edouard philippe
a passé une journée avec moi pour qu'ils
puissent se rendre compte de toutes les
difficultés qu'un handicapé peut avoir
au quotidien